ja ich glaube wir sollten uns langsam
mal darüber klar werden dass wir im
Rahmen der corona-krise einen
medizinischen System Zusammenbruch
erleben wir haben eine
Gesundheitspolitik mit dem Status eines
bananenstaates die medizinischen
Sicherungssysteme funktionieren nicht
mehr die Arzneimittelsicherheit
Institutionen machen nicht mehr ihren
Job und von Anfang an der coronakrise
kamen Leute zu Wort die fachfremd waren
denen die IT die das Fachwissen fehlte
dieser Situation gut einzuschätzen davon
haben wir in Deutschland sehr viele ganz
hervorragende Menschen durch die kamen
nicht zum Einsatz sie hätten uns durch
diese Krise geführt ohne die ganzen
Kollateralschäden als Beispiel möchte
ich nennen die covid-impfkampagne
die beruht auf Zulassungsstudien und
wenn man sich die Pfizer
zuschlassungsstudie anschauen dann ist
die so
ja mir fehlt was die Worte angreifbar es
wurde geschludert das ist inzwischen
belegt es wurden die Zahlen nicht
korrekt ausgewertet das hat gerade eine
neue Publikation zum Beispiel mit dem
Auto das
herausgebershmallows auch gerade
publiziert die das wurde falsch
zusammengerechnet so dass im
Wirklichkeit die impfgruppe mehr
Nebenwirkungen hatte als die
Placebo-Gruppe aus der aus der
impfgruppe wurden Nachhinein 300
Personen aus rausgenommen wir wissen
nicht warum die natürlich das Ergebnis
grandios verfälschen könnten oder
vielleicht hat man es auch deswegen
gemacht es geht ja um Milliarden und
wenn ich dann die Interessenskonflikte
der Autoren lese die entweder Phase
angestellt sind oder ebenfalls er Aktien
haben das aber angeben aber dann zum
Beispiel Autoren wie Herr Sahin und Frau
thüritzsche die Gründer von biontech
keine Interessenskonflikte angeben dann
sind das alles Dinge die bei einer
seriösen Betrachtung wenn die
Zulassungsbehörden sauber arbeiten
würden alle Alarmglocken läuten lassen
und was wir jetzt erleben ist eben dass
man ein Medikament zugelassen hat an den
normalen Standards vorbei mit riesen
Gewinnerwartungen mit einem
wahnsinnsumsatz und die von Kritikern
von Anfang an befürchteten
Nebenwirkungen ja sich zumindest
andeuten in den Zahlen von den
Krankenkassen auch von den
übersterblichkeiten die mit der
Impfkampagne angefangen haben wobei da
noch nicht klar ist ist dass es mehr im
Lockdown zu tun oder mit der
Impfkampagne also wir haben solche
Alarmzeichen dass es ein Wahnsinn ist
jetzt diese bedingte Zulassung bei der
europäischen Arzneimittelkommission in
einer reguläre überzuführen ohne dass
die Daten da sind wir haben früher in
der Medizin da hat das funktioniert wir
haben gefährliche Medikamente wie Lipo
bei oder Sibutramin und das muss ich
erwähnen an den für die Zulassung eben
auch Lauterbach mit Verantwortung
getragen hat nach gefährlichen
Zwischenfällen wieder angenommen wir
haben ein Medikament was ich geliebt
habe als Hausarzt mussaril das entspannt
wollen wir ein paar Momente noch für die
Debatte aufheben können
wie sehen Sie das denn gehen bei Ihnen
auch die Alarmglocken an ja Alarmglocken
würde ich nicht nennen aber was richtig
ist die Publikation von doschi und gibt
ja auch andere Informationen zeigen dass
die
Argumentation von Herrn Lauterbach dass
die Impfung nebenwirkungsfrei ist also
nicht nur komplett an den Haaren
herbeigezogen ist eigentlich für ein
Arzt die Approbation kosten sollte wenn
man sagt dass ein Medikament
nebenwirkungsfrei ist
Gesundheitsministers Kosten müssen das
hat er glaube ich getwittert bevor er
Gesundheitsminister geworden ist aber es
hängt natürlich jemanden an der jetzt
die Arzneimittelsicherheit auch mit
Bundesgesundheitsministerium
nachgeordneten Organen überblicken soll
und da kann auch kann noch nicht der
oberste Chef glauben dass die Impfstoffe
nebenwirkungsfrei sind aber das Auto der
Bürger ja suggeriert genau ist das eine
was suggeriert wird aber vieles anders
auch noch suggeriert eben dass die
Impfung nebenwirkungsfrei ist dass man
die Infektion verhindern kann damit dass
sie Ansteckung nicht mehr da ist dass es
eben auch die jüngeren Leute sich impfen
lassen müssen weil sie ein Vorteil haben
aber der Punkt den die glaube ich haben
mit den im Nebenwirkungen ist der dass
man hier genauer hinschauen muss wir
leben ja in einer sehr dynamischen
Situation und die Daten die zu Anfang
generiert wurden 43.000 Probanden
35000 in der Kontrollgruppe waren robust
würden jetzt noch mal evaluiert man
sieht dort auch Menge handwerkliche
Menge und jetzt sind neue Daten also
muss die Situation dynamisch betrachten
und mit die neuen Daten auch
Nebenwirkung für mich jetzt als Line von
welchen Impfnebenwirkungen sprechen wir
hier von schweren von milderen was kann
es also welche impfnebenwirkung geht am
meisten auf Institut fast das zusammen
es gibt ungefähr
380.000 Verdachtsmeldungen zur
Impfnebenwirkungen auf 182 Millionen
Impfungen in Deutschland oder sieht man
das auch schwere Impfnebenwirkungen vor
Thrombosen die im gehirnauf vorkommen
können oder auch im Bereich des Magens
für die jüngere Leute hauptsächlich
betroffen und das ist ja der Punkt die
Älteren die eigentlich von der meisten
profitieren haben weniger Nebenwirkungen
als jüngeren und die Frage ist ist es
verantwortungsvoll jetzt für eine
Bundesregierung für eine
Bundesoberbehörde diese Indikationen von
Nebenwirkungen ernst zu nehmen oder
nicht man müsste man sagen für junge
Menschen besser dann nicht impfen als zu
impfen also ich stehe da untersten Stufe
der evidenzleiter als einzelexperte da
gibt es eine STIKO das sind Leute die
das weltweite Wissen analysieren
sie die Zuschauer sollen sich ja auch
danach richten oder die Evidenz am
stärksten ist ich glaube
meine Meinung ist die das jetzt die
Daten die ich sehe und ich auch von der
STIKO höre klar sind dass die jünger man
ist desto marginal aber die entwirkung
und desto höher sehen wir jetzt wir sind
die Nebenwirkungen oder der Verdacht das
Wirkung auftreten und das ist jetzt die
Aufgabe jetzt einer sicherlich so eine
Bundesoberbehörde diesen verdeckt diesen
Verdacht nachzugehen deswegen kann man
nicht bedenkenlos im Sommer sagen jeder
der jetzt den Sommer genießen will der
musste jetzt die vierte Impfung egal wie
das Alter ist obwohl man schon wusste
dass auch viele junge Leute betroffen
sind also eine erratische aus meinem
Grund auch entweder ins Freie oder er
wieder ins Arme Kommunikation die
irgendwie dann auch natürlich die Leute
verbrennt
Herr Stör wir haben doch ganz andere
Alarmglocken wir haben die Zahlen der
Krankenkassen wir haben die
rätselhafte Übersterblichkeit Mitte 21
in allen europäischen Ländern bis auf
Schweden komischerweise was wird auf dem
Lockdown hindeutet wir haben doch eine
ganz andere Qualität von Alarm ich meine
in meiner Praxis ist nicht repräsentativ
aber allein was ich schon damit bekommen
habe und das Problem ist doch es wird
regelrecht verhindert dass man das
solide ermittelt ich meine es werden ja
sogar Gesetze gebrochen es stand im
Infektionsschutzgesetz drin dass das
paul-institut bitteschön die Daten von
den Kassenärztlichen Vereinigungen
abfragt ist nicht passiert und hat man
endlich hat man es dann gemacht auf
Druck und was kam raus viel viel mehr
Nebenwirkungen als das diese
Meldesysteme wir wissen doch dass die
Meldesysteme Arzneimittelwirkungen nicht
funktionieren also es wird wirklich eine
ein es ist für mich ein Zusammenbruch
ist ein medizinischer Zivilisationsbruch
was hier passiert hier werden Leute ins
offene Messer gestoßen und wenn sie dann
auch diese neben deswegen haben werden
sie alleine gelassen und jeder jeder
Verantwortliche Medizin muss jetzt sagen
natürlich ich bin ja auch großer im
Freund ja also alle meine Patienten
haben einen suffizienten infastbar
Impfausweis es sei denn Sie möchten es
nicht haben aber ich finde impfen toll
aber diese Impfung ist einfach was
neuartiges da ist unglaublich
gewinndruck dahinter gewesen und die
ganzen medizinischen Sicherheitssysteme
sie raten davon ab unbedingt muss diese
Zulassung gestoppt werden und die
offenen Sicherheitsfrage geklärt werden
keine es gibt keine andere Möglichkeit
weil erstens
sagen alle Lungenärzte seit Omegon gibt
es keine Lungen gibt es keine Pneumonien
mehr angekurved wir haben eigentlich
keine Krankenhaus auch da informiert der
Bundesgesundheitsminister Bevölkerung
völlig irreführend also es gibt
überhaupt kein impfdruck mehr ob die
Impfung für schwere Fälle verhindert hat
muss auch ordentlich untersucht werden
so klar ist es nicht das könnte sein
sie hätte für die Risikogruppen unter
schwer wirklich kontrollierten
Bedingungen
engmaschig zugelassen werden können zu
schauen was passiert aber man hat hier
das einfach auf alle Leute losgelassen
und ich glaube möchte noch mal eine zum
Schluss noch ein Ruf zu Differenzierung
an ich möchte eigentlich sagen diese
diese Aufruf jetzt zum Beispiel
landbaden Württemberg ja das Eltern ihre
Kinder Schulkinder kurvit impfen sollen
und wenn schwören wenn man kranke
Verwandte hat die zweimal provitimpfen
soll halte ich also das kann ich ich
persönlich nicht anders sagen das ist
für mich ein Verbrechen deswegen bin ich
nicht Arzt geworden also das wirklich
mir fehlen jetzt wirklich die Worte wir
müssen da jetzt mal aufhören damit und
wir müssen auch aufhören diese Impfung
zu machenalisieren es geht nicht um
Solidarität es geht nicht um irgendwie
irgendwas sondern es geht darum dass wir
ordentliche arbeiten und Medikamente
ordentlich prüfen bevor man sie an
Leuten ausprobieren und das ist hier
wirklich
gehörigen Schieflage also ich kann
sicherlich bei vielen zustimmen aber ich
glaube die differenzierte
Herangehensweise hilft weiter
dann ist tatsächlich so dass bestimmte
Altersgruppen tatsächlich so wenig
profitieren wie Sie es beschreiben aber
wenn man so herangeht das ist alles
schlecht dann vergisst man dass die
Impfung eigentlich der das exit Ticket
aus der Pandemie war was die schweren
Verläufe betrifft 99% der Todesfälle
sind bei der über 50 Jahre 90% bei über
60 Jahren und die Impfung hat die einen
dramatischen Unterschied gemacht
mitnehmen Wirkung ganz klar die müssen
untersuchen die muss man abwägen muss
man weiter evaluieren das Schlimme was
passiert ist glaube ich dass man die
Untersuchungen jetzt nicht weiter
vorantreiben im Nebenwirkungen bei den
jüngeren Leuten
ganz ganz kurz
weil sie das kann man sagen was ich
sagen aber auch das ist nicht belegt ich
ich möchte das nicht auslesen dass das
ist tatsächlich Leben gerettet hat aber
auch das ist nicht sauber mit wirklich
hochwertigen Studien belegt und die
fehlenden wir kommen jetzt zu dem Punkt
wo sie sich glaube ich hier einig sind
und ich bin mal gespannt ob er anders
vielleicht zur Verteidigung
noch geredet ich glaube Frau Wagenknecht
werden uns ja auch einig sein aber Herr
stört ihre Teesorte an hat ja was mit
dem Gesundheitsminister Karl Lauterbach
zu tun